a funny thing i tend to forget about is  nose hair i have done one of those  machines that plucked everything out and  i  felt like a naked gazelle i felt so sexy  i was like oh my god  nude nostrils everything and then i got  horribly sick and i was like maybe there  is something to those protective fibers  of nose hairs but when the nose hairs do  grow long  powder gets caught in them and it's not  very attractive i'm gonna actually go  with the word disgusting  what i like to do is take these kinds of  scissors you can buy them on amazon or  anywhere they're rounded so you can  actually get right  in the nostril and start trimming around  it  and because they're rounded they won't  cut you  then also like a q-tip and just go  around the inside and make it all nice  and pretty  it's those funny little steps that we  tend to forget but when we go out in the  world  those little details make a big  difference